well it's official I'm dead
all right to have a raft but seriously I
hope this rather finds you well
quite a time you read this I will have
assumed room temperature for a while now
to my everlasting surprise I ended up
here in the lake of fire what a way to
treat a man who got 11 holes in one in
his first game of golf come on I'm
practically a god that's what they
called me in high school the god with
the bond anyway
hell isn't always cracked up to be sure
I hate Wednesday and I have to send you
this email from iMac because apple for
some reason has dead rock down here but
it's not all bad
we shared rooms and get rec time every
day so I can work on personal fitness
I'm now bench pressing 630 pound for rap
so I'm pretty happy about that everybody
Jimmy Carter send me condolence card
yesterday as well $30 gift card to
Cherry's but down here we only have
Applebee's Jimmy always trying to kiss
up to the family
he just said letter to my son wishing
him every success I guess it gives me
that little rascal four-star general
yeah and I'm Elizabeth Taylor what
seriously
he had me rooming with Ted Kennedy and
Osama bin Laden Ted you could take him
or even he's kind of round and smells
like old pencil shavings
but Osama and I really hit it off we've
been working on a real slam-bang comedy
duo act the other day my wife asked me
if I know what I was getting her for
Christmas I said how about a cookbook
that's plenty more where that came from
so be sure to catch me on summer at the
Hades River location
Applebee's bra Friday and Saturday at
7:00 and 9:30 ten dollar cover - gotta
drink minimum anyway miss Perot see I
hope this rather get to you soon because
I wanted to let you know that you should
not worry I spoke to my botulism guy
before I bit the dust and he'll be
hook you up just call the number listed
below and tell him you want the Kim Jong
full hair special he'll know what that
means
come on the guy with the bar take care
of you I just want you to wish you good
luck on the upcoming elections and tell
you that the other day my wife asked me
what was on TV and I tell her ghost
killer because TV was dirty Hades River
Applebee's 7:00 to 9:30 don't miss it